Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 17th,
2014.
I am going to be talking at this volume throughout the whole podcast because
it's seven 24 in the morning.
I'm doing it at my fucking house and I got along fucking day in front of me.
Okay,
so that's the deal.
That's how it's going down.
Already recorded for 20 minutes,
found out the batteries were dead and uh,
I got to start all over again.
Okay.
This close to thanksgiving,
thanksgiving,
everybody a day to give thanks.
It's such a wonderful holiday,
judge.
Your thick,
you know,
you don't have to buy gifts for everybody.
It's just getting together with other people.
I like it so much more than I like Christmas.
It was people always trash Christmas since become this corporate holiday,
very raise gifts.
Got It.
God just by,
by all his stuff and we've totally lost what it really used to be about.
It was about a woman who had never had sex in,
somehow was impregnated by a large being that built everything up in the sky.
She had no say in the matter,
none whatsoever.
She was walking around,
she was in her twenties she was in a relationship with a man and she wasn't
ready.
She wasn't ready.
She wasn't ready for any sort of dicks there.
I set it.
Forget about the biggest dick in the fucking world.
The guy who created everything
somehow puts it in there.
How did he get it in there?
Yo,
I didn't get it in there.
You have to think about that.
How did that work?
That's like a,
that's one of those things like when you see a ship in a bottle,
like how did that get in there?
The build at first and then the bottles of fake and you glue both halves
together,
you know?
Or is there some pirates sitting there with some glue and a pair of fucking
tweezers?
How do you do it?
Nobody knows.
Right?
And she had to go to her man,
right?
That fucking guy yet listen.
Uh,
and I ain't going to blame me.
You know,
this has all been done a zillion times,
but every fucking comic on the planet,
you know what I'm saying?
But anyways,
um,
yeah,
so I'm up here early and I got to knock this thing out because today I got the
sixth and final table read forF is for family,
the,
the uh,
animated show that I'm doing for Netflix that I will be promoting for the next
13 months until it comes out.
Um,
I've been having a great time doing it.
And,
uh,
we're at episode number six.
We do the table read today we're going to record it to Mara.
And,
uh,
then I was thinking I had a little breathing room between I'm doing this one and
then doing another one,
a different show.
But I'm actually,
you are,
we got to an actor to sign on who does not live in Los Angeles and we have to
fly to where they're,
wherever he or she lives,
keeping it vague deliberately.
And we're going to knock out all the,
uh,
all the recordings.
So that's what I have to do for the rest of this week,
whatever.
Then I get a week off and make some fucking pumpkin pie and shit.
And there's your thanksgiving,
right?
Dasia,
thanksgiving,
whatever.
Let's get down to what the fuck I did this week.
So this week I actually,
uh,
mmm.
You know,
I go to one big college football game a year and I wanted to go to the,
you know,
we decided,
me and my buddies,
the hurricanes,
Miami Dolphins,
the hurricanes fucking Florida state game.
And then the Miami Dolphins,
buffalo bills had a game Thursday.
So we're like,
why don't we knock them both out?
And then Friday night I'll work the fucking Improv and West Palm Beach,
which is exactly what,
what we did.
And a dude,
I got to tell you,
we fucking did it up right,
man.
We bought,
we all,
we rented this fucking house right on the fucking water.
You know,
beautiful house,
beautiful fucking house that you can afford to rent but could never afford to
live there.
MMM.
I'll tell you what was nuts was having now bought a house that I thought was a
beautiful house and then found out all the problems that had.
MMM.
I actually walked around and all the guys they would loan.
It was a beautiful fucking house and I just,
just looking at it now,
it isn't,
no,
I saw all kinds of fucking issues.
All right.
The hot tub.
Okay.
The water was having a difficult time getting hot.
All right.
I'd say that's about 4,500 bucks right there.
Figuring out what that is.
You know,
you had a bunch of loose tile over near the shallow end and the pool,
I don't know what was going on there.
It seems like there was some sort of a water seepage into the ground,
Ej that caused the concrete underneath the tiles to fail.
That's at least three fucking grant.
Then they had a steam shower and the door didn't close properly and the steam
when you turned it on with just keep coming out until you shut it off.
It didn't have any sort of shut off on it.
So all of that right there.
I just saw 12 grand with the fucking problems and I'm not even in the house yet,
so I can only imagine what is inside the walls.
See,
that's what owning a home is,
has done for me.
Now.
I don't even look at the overall layout of it.
I'm looking for fucking watermarks in the ceilings or the walls.
You know,
I'm looking to see if windows closed flush or not.
Any of that type of shit.
I'm completely jaded.
So anyways,
let me get 'em.
Let's get to the story here.
So anyways,
yeah,
me and uh,
you know,
Paul Versey and a couple other buddies,
vice starting,
you know,
go to these big college games every year.
So we assumed,
you know,
we went to the house that it was just going to be the four of us,
right?
Four or five,
that's what I thought it was going to be.
And we show up to this house and it was the four or five of us plus like,
I don't know,
I don't even know how many other guys were staying there.
It turns this place like this beer company rented it out.
So we didn't have to kick any money in,
and then they stock the fridge with all their beer and then all their bullshit
that doesn't sell like all those ciders and all that fucking horse shit.
Um,
so,
and then all those other guys that we didn't know also invited some other people
and it was like fucking,
I don't know,
like 12 people in the house.
It was fucking hilarious.
Like I would literally went in there,
I had no idea who was,
who,
who was staying,
who was friends with people staying,
right.
Sort of that shady type of thing.
There's not a lock on your door.
You're like,
thank God I got a computer in there.
The sunglasses.
What the fuck are these people cool?
You have no idea who anybody is.
I felt like I was on like the fucking,
like if the real world did like an over 40 episode of their show,
like that's what it felt like.
Um,
fortunately everybody turned out to be a like,
totally cool.
But um,
I gotta tell you there was one fucking morning though,
if that was so god damn hilarious.
Uh,
what's his face?
Paul Versey.
As I've told you before,
I've told you this shit before on other podcasts that Paul Versey
not only is not a morning person,
he might be like the biggest like non morning person.
I think I've ever met in my life.
Like the fucking look on his face when,
when he gets woken up before he feels he should be woken up.
I swear to God,
I can't even describe the,
it's like he looks like he's walking out of court and he just lost the case and
he was 100% right.
And He's already mental ease mentally getting past that and thinking about how
he's going to take justice into his own hands.
You know,
like he's going to fucking kneecap somebody.
That's if you wake them up 20 minutes early,
right.
So we're in this fucking house.
All right.
And everybody in there is a married guy.
And for you youngsters out there,
I don't know if you've ever party,
but like married guys,
like truly married guys like me and Versie are married.
But like,
you know,
we go on the road like every other week,
every other week.
You know,
you get some rnr,
you'll walk away from it.
But these guys truly married guys,
those guys that fucking wake up,
wife and kids,
right?
Get in the car,
go to work,
come back home,
wife and kids wake up the next day,
wife and kids and all this shit that comes with that.
Right?
Susie chipped a tooth on the coffee table and don't forget my keys.
Teeball game and a,
there's a dance recital.
I,
I a Jesus Christ,
right fucking get in the car,
go to work,
coming home.
Can you pick up some more fucking yeast,
whatever.
Fuck you gotta do come home wife and kids,
you get the deal.
Those fucking guys
when they go go away and they get three days like you'll never see somebody go
fucking
okay,
they'll drink college kids under the table.
These guys will fucking animals.
I almost gave him a standing ovation,
the level with which that they would,
they would like drinking until like three,
four o'clock in the morning and then they would be up again at like 9:00 AM the
same fucking guys.
Yeah.
Which is no big deal if you're a youngster.
But these guys were in their forties,
that's not done.
That's like Darrell Green still running a four 40 when he was like 41 years old.
This is the alcoholic version of it.
Right.
So what was hilarious was they had surround sound in that house.
So like,
you know,
late at night when they had the music on,
like I want to go to bed and it's fucking cranked in my room.
But fortunately there's a volume that you have.
You go when you're turning,
you shut it off.
So anyway,
so we all go to bed at like three,
four o'clock in the fucking morning,
the first night.
All right.
And um,
I gotta be up early cause I got a punch up this script for this week.
I got two,
three hours of work that I have to do,
so I'm going to be up at nine anyway,
so I didn't go too hard the first night.
Um,
but these fucking guys like eight 30 in the morning,
all of a sudden the stereo just fucking comes on.
And I had my speaker turned off,
but you know,
it's just,
you know,
the,
the living room area they had that,
you know,
there was no
okay.
Uh,
the ceiling when all the way up to the second force floor ceiling.
So when you walked in the hallway upstairs,
you looked off the balcony and you looked out through these windows out to the
pool,
onto the water,
it was fucking amazing.
Right?
But,
um,
you start cranking a fucking stereo.
Okay.
With all of that,
that space for all the sounds to bounce off the fucking wall,
dude,
it sounded like a goddamn constant.
Right?
And they're crank in this shit.
I'm hating it.
Make that making Margaritas,
that fucking the Shane,
right.
Crush it up the ice.
And all I'm thinking of is Versie.
So I'm laying in bed laughing my fucking ass off because I know first he's going
to come down those stairs with the look on his face,
like he's going to fucking murder everybody,
right?
Um,
and then on top of that,
there was a couple hurricane fans there and they started doing those chairs.
They're out by the pool doing that.
It's great to be me,
hurricane or oh,
you guys cage,
right?
Screaming.
Uh,
sure enough,
about three minutes into this shit,
I get a text from [inaudible] all in capital letters.
He goes,
dude,
when did the fucking orchestra start?
What the fuck?
A question mark.
20 exclamation points.
So I'm fucking dying laughing and uh,
and I'm trying to punch up the script.
I'm just this,
you know,
don't want the best I can.
You know,
this is what happens.
You stay with a bunch of other guys,
you've got to fucking deal with other people,
right?
So,
okay,
that doing this shift for like an hour and a half,
just getting fucking loaded.
Um,
I'm trying to punch up the script and verse.
He's losing fucking mind.
And then at of right around 11 o'clock in the morning and granted it's 11
o'clock in the morning,
but we had been drinking to like three,
four o'clock in the morning.
There was a guitar in the House and one of these married dudes picks this
fucking thing up.
He had a great voice.
But what the fuck,
right.
He starts playing this thing.
Okay.
He's,
he played like he was playing a Bon Jovi's wanted dead or alive just sitting out
there.
He just starts banging on the guitar and I'll send you just like singing right
in that area where you've got,
you know,
it goes all the way up to the second floor ceiling sitting right in the family
room.
They all of a sudden you just hear this guy going,
it's all the say.
Oh Jay age.
Right.
And then when he got to the chorus,
somebody else was singing the Richie Sambora part.
So He'd be like,
cause I'm walnut.
Did he hit somebody else by the pool?
Whoa.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden I get a text,
some version he just likes,
he writes really all capital letters.
And then like 20 explanation points of Eh,
exclamation points and fucking question marks.
Oh my God,
Dude.
I was laying in this bed,
fucking crying,
laughing in every song was getting more annoying if you were trying to sleep
this dude,
you fucking sank Paul.
Simon's 50 ways to leave your lover,
which is a fucking hilarious song because the like the verse is like whispered
and then it gets fucking loud during the course,
like a Nirvana Song,
you know?
So he's just sitting there and in the living room,
you know,
the problem is all inside your head.
She said to me,
Andrew is easy.
If you take a,
I don't have the data,
there must be 50 ways to leave your lover,
50 ways to leave your lover.
Then he just screams,
come on everybody.
He just slipped back to back.
Jack just fucking wailing on this guitar.
Um,
and the Margarita Margarita machine was going,
I just,
I was just fucking laughing the whole time,
punching up this fucking script or whatever.
And uh,
okay.
So then we get out there and I'm telling you,
dude,
like,
nope,
nope.
Like nobody fucking drinks like that.
College kids,
I guess we'll drink like that,
but it's understandable.
He's like,
Oh my God,
I'm a wait for my parents.
Right.
There's a different kind of desperation that a married guy who's just fucking
locked in a married guy that doesn't cheat,
doesn't fuck around.
You know what I mean?
His only outlet is this three days that he's out there and he is drinking every
drop of fucking alcohol do this.
I don't want fucking cannon balls into the pool.
Okay.
Was Insane.
It was fucking funny.
I already miss it.
That's so much fun.
I had um,
so many ways.
Uh,
so that night we ended up going to the uh
yeah
to the Miami Dolphin Buffalo Bill game and uh,
we had a hookup.
We got to go down onto the field right before,
uh,
you know the game watching those guys working out duty can't fucking believe how
big they are.
You just looking at a guy like go on that,
that's a running back.
That's not a linebacker,
that's a running back gigantic.
And you sit there and you remember their numbers,
which is cool.
Cause then when you get up there and you see him on the field,
they look small again next to a defensive lineman or a linebacker.
They actually look like a running back.
But when they're standing next to you,
it's like a,
you know,
they look like fucking iron man.
You know,
you know whenever you go to those fucking places with those stores where they
have the hours,
the actual alphabet worn by an actor,
it was six what floor?
And it's made all of metal.
That's what the fuck these guys look like.
So,
um,
we ended up going up there and a dude,
I got to tell you something.
Okay.
In all my years going to a sporting events that Miami dolphins game might have
been the biggest collection of fucking animals I've ever been around.
Okay.
It was doing,
it was unfucking believable.
Do Florida is,
I dunno what the deal is with Florida and I know there's a lot of beautiful
people down there and there's a lot of beautiful people and they got money and
all of that type of shit,
but they do not go to a dolphins game.
Fucking animals.
You combine that with the bills fans,
bunch of married guys who got away for three days and they were drinking at the
level that they were drinking do we were in this,
we were sitting in our row.
Right,
okay.
And there was like four or five different people who just either stepped over a
row to go up or down and sat in different seats.
It was like a free for all.
Anybody could sit wherever they wanted.
There was a guy next to me eating a fucking hammered like 50 something years
old,
just absolutely fucking wasted eating this fucking hot dog.
Okay.
With ketchup and onions on it.
I swear to God it looks like he was,
he was doing the David Hasselhoff video when he fucking hate it.
The hamburger,
he was getting it all over his face.
His hands.
He had onions with ketchup.
Okay.
You don't think that when they dice them up,
just like,
like snow flakes all over his fucking pants and then he's leaning into me to
talk to me covering and onions and ketchup.
God,
I love how I can I go for a ride down fucking complete animals.
Um,
and then the worst part was littered within that.
You'd see some older fans,
like older couples,
cute older people,
you know,
with Bob Greasy and Jim Lange or fucking jerseys sitting there and you're trying
to think like,
are they thinking like what happened?
But then again,
they also went to football games during the 70s so God knows what the hell they
saw.
I don't know.
All I know it was so fucked up.
Okay.
At halftime we actually left and went inside and kind of just fucking regrouped
and just tried to find an area where we could sit where you could just be away
from that do I had like fucking like three beers spilled on me.
We were in the lower level two and I expect that the upper level of any fucking
stadium,
you expect that behavior.
But I was like down here I was like,
wait,
where's the corporate people?
Where's the Illuminati Illuminati money,
you know,
where's the people who are profiting off the war?
Right.
Where are those for nowhere to be found.
Just a bunch of fucking animals.
So,
uh,
so here's the funny thing.
As I'm sitting there fucking judge in them.
Um,
I mean,
dude,
these people were so fucking drunk and so fucking gross,
like in,
it made me feel like,
dude,
I don't think I ever want to go to another live sporting event.
I would rather be home.
Having said all of that,
uh,
we go to the fucking Miami Hurricane,
f Mari,
Miami Hurricane Fsu game,
and I literally became that guy.
I became that dolphins fan.
I minus the fucking food all over me.
I don't know what happened,
Dude.
I just fucking,
I drank way too much.
Uh,
yeah.
Jesus.
I'm still thinking about things that I said at that game and just kind of gone.
You know,
like when you think of dumb shit you do,
you just kind of,
I always make noise when I think of shit that I did
try to drown out the thought from your fucking head.
I'll tell you that story in a second.
Let me do a little bit of advertising here.
All right,
everybody,
here we go.
It's time again for me.
Undies,
me,
undies,
me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
me undies.
Mandy's,
you got to go buy a all walking down the street where dry fucking balls walking
around with no smelly balls.
I got,
if I got to finish writing this song,
oh,
walking around with me undies.
You really got to love your balls.
Oh yeah,
you're really going to be nice and dry booboo.
Don't forget about your taint.
We really mean it.
You take but dab at eh and your bones
nice and dry at the mall.
Sorry,
90% that's the percent of your life that you,
you are in on your underwear and underwear.
It gets old fast.
It's unbelievable how putting on a great pair of underwear,
it changes your entire outlook for the day.
This is not a joke.
You know that feeling of putting on old ratty saggy underwear.
I want you to know the feeling of wearing great fitting,
great looking underwear.
You need to know about me undies.com may Hyundai has the most comfortable
underwear you have ever tried on.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture away from your skin
grows.
So you're cool all day long,
dude.
Who are these people walking around with like sweaty fucking balls and you're
playing hope.
You just getting up from your cubical walking over,
hey,
go over to the bubbler.
It's coming through your slacks.
Um,
here's what I love.
Evidently according to the copy copy here me undies is environmentally friendly.
Yeah.
Not fes skid are in there,
I wouldn't think,
but that's not the underwears fault.
That's the fucking not poisoned food that we eat.
Uh,
the materials they use are sustainably sourced from the Austrian Alps and they
are completely natural.
They also use a CO2 neutral process with the low carbon footprint.
They save water and energy due to their spun dried fiber process.
Do it.
If you're not going to get a pair of these,
I don't know what else you'd think.
This is like,
all you do is you're reading this,
you just picturing this up against your bulls there.
Um,
they have cool styles for both men and women.
Oh,
sorry,
I forgot about the veggies and all.
Look Great.
Check out the photos for yourself.
Me undies,
ed,
me,
undies.com this quality would typically retail two times to me.
Undies.
Price.
No retail middlemen means more savings for you here.
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them.
Or your first pair is free.
Here,
I'll help you out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order of 20% off
your order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and right now you'll even get it.
You'll even get free shipping in the United States and Canada.
All right.
Um,
come on.
You know you need a new one to wear.
All right.
I buy new underwear like once every fucking
okay.
I don't even know.
Five years,
seven.
I mean they don't,
they're not like all ratty and stuff,
but that definitely what did it,
what does that like,
you know when you,
you sweat it gets old.
They get a little pilled up there.
All right,
the man,
great.
Everybody attention grill masters.
This holiday season there was only one gift.
That is is an absolute must have the man.
Great.
What is a man great.
You ask,
maybe you didn't ask but either way I'm going to tell you man,
great.
Sorry.
American made a high quality 100% cast iron grill grates that sit right on top
of your agree,
your existing great.
Those little Wiki,
little a aluminum ones that you have.
This is an upgrade.
This is like pulling out the four cylinder and dropping in,
you know?
Okay.
Whatever the hell,
a four 54 whatever those gearheads use a weighing in at eight pounds.
A piece man greats ensures,
ensures juicy,
tender meat with no flare ups and perfect.
See your marks every time.
Man.
Greats patented design delivers stay couch quality flavor right at your home.
Take advantage of the Monday morning podcast,
holiday special,
and get 33% off your entire order.
Also,
for a limited time,
every three man,
great.
You order,
you get four,
you get the fourth man,
great for free.
Just head over to man,
great.com and enter my coupon code.
[inaudible],
B U.
R.
R,
a checkout.
All right,
once again there,
100% made in America a hundred percent cast iron.
You get 33% off your entire order when you enter burr at checkout.
I'm limited time.
Order three man grades.
Get the fourth one for free.
Make sure you go to man.
Great job.
Come and enter my cop,
my coupon code [inaudible] at checkout.
These razor,
even Bruton more brutal than ever.
I'm just fucking,
I'm still hung over from everything I did over the weekend.
All right,
draft kings.com everybody draft kings million.
It's a million ads up.
Be in Maine all season long at draft kings,
not calm.
America's favorite one week fantasy football site one week.
Fantasy means no season long commitments play whoever you want,
play whenever you want.
Got An injured player.
No problem@draftkings.com it's like a new season every week,
so you are never stuck with the same players.
Pick your team in minutes and you could be on your way to winning huge cash this
season.
One listener turn 10 bucks into five grant another turn,
$2 in a 10 grand and a new millionaire has been crown nearly every week.
This season@draftkings.com you could pay next.
Imagine winning $1 million in one day just playing fantasy football because of
that website right there.
draftkings.com a call to action.
Get free entry into their hundred thousand dollars fantasy football contest this
week.
We're first place takes home 10 grand.
Head to head to draft kings.com now and enter the Promo code cracked.
C R a C K e d to play for free draft kings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter cracked.
C R a C K e d for free entry now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkings.com that is once
again,
draft kings.com.
Um,
all right,
I'll save your fucking ears.
I'll read another couple later.
Um,
oh,
I've got to promote some two things I've got to promote.
Uh,
for those of you who worked a lot this past week,
you might have missed it.
I did a very special episode of the Monday morning podcast with the,
um,
okay,
I'm sorry the fucking battery went between the Goddamn cushion,
God dammit.
Uh,
set these down and we go with Joe Perry from Aerosmith,
everyone the one and only Joe Perry,
part of one of the greatest lead singer lead guitar to Tara's Tandems in rock
music histories.
Tyler Perry,
right?
Holy Shit.
Tyler Perry.
I hadn't even thought about that.
Tyler Perry presents an Aerosmith albums,
Jagger,
Richards,
Tyler Perry.
I never even thought of that.
Um,
anyways,
it was a great interview and I had a great time with him and I deliberately did
not go into all of the stupid fucking,
you know,
so what's it like to,
uh,
get on stage and play?
Good.
I asked a couple of Music Geek questions,
but I've always found with those guys,
you know,
just to give them a break.
If you talk about a bunch of other shit,
they really can have a good time.
And uh,
you know,
so we talked about rather than talking about rock music and what was it like in
the 70s and all that,
I did a little bit of that shit.
I tried to do it in a way.
Um,
I uh,
I don't know.
We talked about home invasion owning a gun,
some of the worst torture,
like ways to die and I'm,
and he was right there,
right there with it.
Very well read man.
And uh,
we had a great time and actually somebody uh,
sent me a question about,
it was like a Joe Perry,
dear bill,
dear Billy.
It was a blind man.
Uh,
then I guess that's an Aerosmith song reference in case you missed it that late
nineties hit while dude,
they have like 9 million hits.
You got to get a little more specific than that.
I said I love the Perry podcasts so much.
I heard him on Rogan and opion Jimmy and he sounds like the coolest guy ever.
He is the coolest guy ever considering.
I showed up with my little bullshit apparatus,
two microphones and I forgot a Mike Cord and he goes,
Oh yeah,
my neighbors got one and he got up and ran over there to go get one.
He came back,
it was the wrong thing,
didn't fit.
He ran back over again and I'm sitting alone in his frigging house going,
Joe Perry is going to get me a Mike Court.
Like,
like it's no biggie.
That's how fucking cool that guy,
he's,
I was so fucking embarrassed.
Listen to it.
You'll hear,
you'll hear it.
Um,
all of that on there anyways.
Uh,
he goes,
no excuses.
You have to have him back on.
Oh good.
I'm glad you liked the interview.
I don't do a lot of those.
I said next time block off two hours so we can get our feel.
How surreal is it that you know him and that he's a fan of yours?
I know you're not the biggest name dropper,
no names.
He says,
uh,
but who else have you befriended since becoming the famous stud you are,
that blows your mind every time you think about it.
Sincerely,
no name from East Boston Kid East Boston kid.
All right.
Well,
um,
I wouldn't say,
uh,
I have,
um,
a cult following.
I am at a very cool level of notoriety.
Right.
Which is a good thing considering my behavior at the fucking Florida State Miami
hurricane game.
Oh my God.
Did I get fucking hammered?
I woke up so fucking hung over that I wasn't really,
um,
you know,
I wasn't really a
keen on drinking,
so I started slow because the night before.
Oh,
well let me back up here for a second.
Or should I ask answer the Joe Perry question?
I'll answer the Joe Perry question first and then I'll tell the whole fucking
story of my,
my last weekend out there in Fort Lauderdale.
Um,
all right.
So what is your question?
Who else have I befriended since people started to know me?
Um,
you know,
and I don't know people,
few people here or there,
you know?
Yeah,
it does,
you know,
blows your mates more like people.
Um,
yeah,
you don't,
it really is.
It's people who were famous before I got into this business,
you know what I mean?
As opposed to like,
you know,
a lot of people will come famous now,
like 20 years younger than I am.
So I just look at him and I just see,
I just see some kid,
you know,
driving around in a Ferrari and I just think,
uh,
I hope that person saves them money because this Oh till his proof,
his business is a rough on,
you know,
and that's all I think,
so I don't really go like,
you know,
I,
I guess it's,
yeah,
it's people that,
um,
athletes and um,
and entertainers that when I was a kid and they were bigger than life.
Like if I meet anybody who played football,
hockey,
basketball,
baseball,
um,
when I was a kid,
uh,
like,
oh,
well when I was down on the sidelines,
I ended up meeting a nat more,
uh,
put that video up.
But he was famous when he got hit and he helicoptered around is still held onto
the ball.
Um,
to me that's fucking cooler than meeting.
Uh,
I dunno,
kid rock or something like that.
Nothing against kid rock.
He just was in knowledge kid to me.
And I don't mean that in a disrespectful way.
I mean I'm happy for him and all that type of stuff,
but it was just like I didn't grow up on his music by the time that guy hit,
I was well into my thirties fucking up my 20th goddamn relationships.
So I was just in a different place.
Like music means so much to you when you're in your teenage years.
So,
um,
obviously Joe Perry is a big name,
but I don't name names and I don't.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I just always feel like those people are completely inundated with that shit.
Last thing they need is somebody else talking about them.
Uh,
so I will say as far as like the etiquette when you do meet somebody like that
is you don't ask for a picture.
You don't ask for an autograph.
And if you have any fucking sorta sense is you don't talk about all the shit
that they've done because they've talked about it to death.
And the last thing,
the last thing,
like,
I dunno a fuck egg.
If you met somebody who landed on the moon,
do you met one of those guys?
The last thing they want to talk about is what it was like to land on the
fucking moon.
They'd been talking about it since 1969 if he can somehow find out what their
hobby is
like,
say you got a fucking astronaut and he's into gardening and you actually know a
little bit about growing fruits and vegetables.
If you actually talk to that guy about that at a fucking party,
that guy's eyes would fucking lock in on you like a laser.
Cause he finally gets to talk about something else.
That's a theory.
I have some people like talking about the shit that they do.
Um,
but anyways,
you asked me a yeah,
like Joe Perry.
That is definitely someone you know,
uh,
that I still,
you know,
you just looking at him going like,
yeah,
that's fucking Joe Perry.
It's fucking Joe Perry.
And he's sitting here and I'm interviewing him and he's right next to a guitar.
And despite the fact I want to ask him to pick it up and show me how to play
toys in the attic,
I'm going to fucking do it.
MMM.
But anyways,
yeah.
Well it would also helps too if you,
if you're doing the interview,
if you've got to know the person a little bit and you find out all the other
shit that they're into.
But I,
I figured that out a long time ago.
Uh,
I did,
uh,
um,
I helped us isn't coming off like an arrogant ass.
It's another reason why I know fucking drop any names because,
oh,
what was doing this?
And I was hanging out with this guy.
Um,
I was doing this thing for,
uh,
the baseball awards where they like give out the cy young award and all that.
And they have,
we wanted to have a comedian there just in case the,
uh,
the baseball players weren't being funny and what killed me was not only they
were they funny,
they will fucking hilarious and they told great stories and then I felt like I
wasn't even worthy of being there.
MMM.
I remember Willie Randolph in particular was fucking hilarious cause he had just
left the Yankees to,
to manage the mets.
MMM.
And he was really funny,
you know,
talking shit to the Yankees and Joe Torry and all those guys.
So,
uh,
anyways,
I'm standing backstage waiting to go on and Bernie Williams is there and I was
like,
okay.
And I just went through the Rolodex.
Alright,
last thing you want to say is what's it like to play center field for the
Yankees?
Because he,
he'll answer it,
he'll just glaze over.
But I had seen on the yes network,
you know,
that he was a musician and he played with his band.
He was actually really fucking good.
So I just started talking music to the guy.
Oh wait,
this was afterwards,
this was afterwards I started talking music with them.
And he just totally fucking that glazed over.
I'm super famous,
look,
went away and it was just talking to him and then all of a sudden this other
baseball player who I think was pissed because the red sox had just beat the
Yankees.
Okay.
For the first time ever when we were down three games to none and I gave him a
little bit of shit like just to crowd in general.
And I think he was mad at me and he came walking up and just like put this
fucking ridiculous energy was just ignoring me and staring at the side of Bernie
Williams head.
And it kind of was like,
all right guys,
see you later.
And I walked away.
To this day,
I wish,
I wish they said something,
but he seemed like he was fucking pissed.
Um,
tell what happened.
I'm just some punk comedian,
so I fucking walked away.
So anyways,
yeah.
So anybody famous,
I've done a couple of table reads where,
okay.
You know,
uh,
actually I did a table read with one of the guy or you made a reference to him
eating a fucking hamburger.
I did a table read with him and he was the coolest fucking dude ever and looked
great.
Like you just looked at the guys like that guy had to be a fucking movie star.
Look at him,
look at them.
It's fucking ridiculous looking.
And I was totally cool and a funny son of a bitch,
but,
uh,
I don't really name names or anything like that.
Um,
but yeah,
that answers the question.
If,
if they were famous and they,
I love what they did when I was a kid.
It's fucking over.
You know what I mean?
Like if I met Tom Brady,
you know,
hey,
all right,
whatever.
But if I met Steve Grogan,
a Mac Cavenaugh was Sam Cunningham,
dawn Calhoun,
right?
John Hannah,
Raymond Clayborne,
those guys.
Cedric Maxwell,
Terry O'Reilly,
Stan,
Jonathan.
If I meet those fucking guys,
I,
I turned into a little schoolgirl.
Uh,
yeah,
I meet Tom Brady.
I just feel old and I'm reminded that I never made it to the NFL.
No disrespect.
That's all.
I'm speaking a Tom Brady.
How about that can huge when I'm starting to become a fucking believer.
Okay,
I can,
can you even,
can you believe anything this year in the NFL?
I hope you're not gambling this year.
And if you,
if you're gambling this year and you're actually making money,
there's no way you're,
you're actually looking at the information and making any sort of intelligent
gas because there's nothing to even like the analyst on TV sitting there going
like,
well,
what,
what do you do with this?
What do you do with this information here?
Um,
okay.
Every other week,
like some team that looks like they're,
the team completely falls apart and then another team comes on.
So now all of a sudden the patriots,
after looking like they were finished,
they had written them off.
They'd beaten the Broncos and the colts.
Now the dumb football fan goes,
yeah,
that's it.
That means we're the best team in the AFC rather than just going like,
that was just a fucking regular season game in October or November.
Um,
okay.
I love that we beat those teams,
but,
uh,
sometimes I actually wish you lose those ones because I think it's easier when
you get into the playoffs and you're already lost.
For some reason.
It always seems like the team that lost comes back and when,
so,
um,
I don't see us getting to the big dance there without having to play the colts
and the Broncos,
at least one of them,
if not both of them again.
Um,
okay.
You know,
and as my buddy Keith Robinson,
okay,
the always sunshiny Keith Robinson was saying is that if the Broncos go out and
they sign,
um,
okay,
the guy who fucking with this kid with a tree branch on his ball bag,
if they sign him or the guy who dropped the chicken,
the fucking elevator Fisa,
if they signed one of them,
you know,
they signed one of them,
then all of a sudden they have a running game and we suck against the run.
Although we looked pretty good last night.
Uh,
I'll tell you right now,
that's a completely different blog posts.
Chaman achievement showed up back in October.
Um,
dude,
how annoying are those?
No more commercials.
Fucking unbelieved that.
Just the whole tone of those within they,
they're talking to you like,
you know,
a woman that's been beaten that's being beaten and you're not saying anything.
It's like,
dude,
that's what you guys did.
Why don't you show that video to yourself?
Do you realize how debt the fucking mind?
Fuck the fuck on that thing.
They did the thing that then they did the thing right now and now they're
yelling at you like you did it no more.
Okay,
no more.
She closed the refrigerator door and forgot to take her fucking head out,
right?
Yeah.
Stop looking the other way.
Can you fucking believe the balls of the NFL to come at their fan base with that
fucking tone sitting there watching your product so you're making money and all
of a sudden you're going to start yelling at me for this shit.
You did.
You fucking stuffed suit.
Cont unfucking believable.
You watch that fucking video.
Um,
okay.
I would only get me started on all of that shit.
All of this debt,
that whole getting offended thing.
Can you believe that scientists had to apologize for that comic con fucking
shirt he was wearing after landing and unmanned fucking drone on a comet that's
hurling through space.
Yeah.
He had to apologize.
Who the fuck are they apologizing to?
I don't know anybody who's a member of a group.
I don't know anybody who sends in complaints.
I don't know anybody who gets offended.
I don't know anybody.
It's fucking unreal,
dude.
It's like getting offended now.
It's like a,
yeah,
it's not even,
it's not even truly being offended anymore.
It's just,
it's like a,
it's like a marketing move.
It's like,
okay,
everybody tweet in three,
two,
one,
boom,
and then you have 500 tweets,
the same fucking thing and then it starts trending.
We do that at all things comedy,
like we have a big,
we're trying to raise money here for our,
uh,
for our new studios to get some high quality equipment in there and we just
don't tweet out at the same time.
And then all of a sudden it becomes a little movement there.
But that doesn't mean the whole world is thinking what all things comedy is
thinking.
Right?
That Jesus,
what am I talking?
All right,
let's get to the fucking game.
So anyways,
so after we,
uh,
we did,
the show out in West Palm Beach.
Um,
we came back and I bought probably the greatest assortment of cumin Cuban cigars
ever amassed
by a redheaded balding freckled guy,
46 years of age in the fucking West Palm beach area,
whatever.
I brought a great selection of cigars,
but like 25 fucking cigars,
I brought enough cigars so everybody,
the,
the four people that I thought were going to be there,
so we all could smoke three a day if we want it to.
I knew I would have some leftover.
So we're hopping away late at night,
laughing our balls off.
Me and Versie for the 9000000th time had the Matt Cassel fucking argument.
Um,
you know,
where he said the Patriots made a big mistake and getting rid of the guy ain't
Keiji Dude,
the,
he won 11 games and I kept going with the team that won 16.
Paul,
that's a five e one less fucking games.
That's like 30% less games.
So if that team was nine and seven,
30% less of fucking nine games,
three games,
now that team goes six and 10.
Do you understand that?
You just keep looking at 11 games.
A fucking drove me nuts.
All right.
Then he goes out to Casey,
he gets hurt and they fucking cheer.
Midwestern,
classy fucking people.
They cheer.
So anyways,
we had that fight till like four in the mall.
It's just a great,
just a great hang.
You know,
just sitting there smoking cigars out by the pool right near the fucking water
is the greatest goddamn thing ever.
And then we go to bed,
we wake up the next day,
the fucking blenders going.
The Guitar Guy had gone home.
I missed the guy,
man.
I wanted him to fucking wake up for z again cause it was just too fucking funny.
Um,
he had already gone home.
Great Dude.
And then,
um,
we fucking,
uh,
these guys start drinking and I'm drinking waters for like the first two hours
I'm up,
I'm drinking waters,
I'm doing the right thing.
And then,
uh,
I cracked open my first beer and then I didn't want to get a beer belly.
I started drinking fucking crown royal and uh,
still sober,
took a cab to the game.
Everything's going great.
We get out there and this is funny thing,
now we go to the exact same fucking stadium where we went and we saw those
dolphin fans,
all of them looking like they just dress like they just survived a fucking
hurricane and grabbed whatever they could put on before they walked out.
Honestly,
one of the most depressing fan bases I've ever seen in my fucking life.
The Miami Dolphin fans.
Then you go to the Miami Hurricane Fsu game,
completely night and day.
Unbelievably festive fucking atmosphere.
Bunch of young people,
they get their lives ahead of them.
All right,
good looking people.
It was just a great,
that college football spirit,
people singing songs,
doing the chin.
It was fucking awesome.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I started with the whiskeys and I just kept going.
And,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
I don't know what happens to me.
I don't even like the hurricanes,
but I get when I go to these games every year,
I root for the fucking home team and they've yet to win.
All right.
I went to a and M Alabama law last year
in college station,
Alabama wins
the year before that,
Lsu,
Alabama
in Baton Rouge,
Alabama wins year before that I went to fucking Texas,
Oklahoma,
the Red River game.
I know that they play at the cotton bowl neutral site,
but it's in Texas,
Oklahoma wins.
And now this year,
Miami hurricanes in Miami and Fsu wins [inaudible] amount of fucking Fsu fans
that I fucking was given shit too.
Like I cared.
I didn't even care as they were doing that Tomahawk Chop.
Whoa.
I was singing at the top of my lungs aside,
you fat.
Fuck it was fucking brutal.
Made a complete spectacle of myself,
you know,
and the hurricanes came out just fucking killing them in the first half.
And he just knew you saw it,
you saw it,
you just saw it.
Too much time left.
They had to come out and score and they fucking didn't.
Their field goal kicker missed an extra point and a fucking field goal.
And I keep living in adversity shit cause he wants to get rid of the extra
point.
Did it fucking 99% of them the mic.
Yeah.
There's that 1% that adds the goddamn drama.
So anyways,
um,
I apologize to anybody who saw me at that game.
And uh,
once again,
I'm on the wagon.
I still had like five Cuban cigars left and I just left him at the house.
I just said I got to walk away from that habit.
Um,
and I'm not going to drink or smoke until a new year's day one,
I'm at the Rose Bowl and then I'll make another spectacle.
And Myself,
I guess,
you know,
some that guy earlier when he was trying to say that,
uh,
you know,
when I was telling him I just had a certain level of notoriety,
um,
I am right about that because my behavior at these football games,
the fact that there's no cell phone video of it,
um,
let you know where I'm at in this,
this,
this business of show.
Um,
all right,
let's read some of this stuff.
Oh Man.
Hey,
did anybody watch real sports with Bryant Gumbel this week and see,
saw the absolute genius Joe Rogan,
one of my favorite comics of all time was on there.
Um,
I didn't even know what he was on there.
And then we'll talking about a city people who are going out and hunting their
own meat,
you know,
killing deer and wild pigs in shit.
Um,
so this is a little suffering as possible,
so there's no drugs or that type of thing.
Hopefully,
you know,
um,
really,
really interesting thing.
And I wanted,
they were watching them slaughter in the cows and the pigs and all,
and the chickens and shit.
Every time I see that,
I always think,
man,
I,
I can't,
I can't be a part of that.
I got to learn how to be a fucking vegetarian or,
or find out where the fucking,
you know,
the one where they just wa I dunno.
It's just fucking awful.
Okay.
Fucking awful.
I mean,
but then it's weird like,
you know,
out in the wild,
they all die fucking horrific deaths as all the wilderness is.
It's just murder going on all the fucking time out there.
Okay.
I Dunno,
but there's gotta be a better fucking way.
I hate when they sit there and then,
I don't know,
there's just something about it.
I Dunno.
I like animals,
but also like a good steak,
you know?
Maybe you know what I'll do.
I'll sell fucking knock it down.
The consumption of it a lot.
I don't know why it's fucking bad.
I am actually excited that watching Bryant Gumbel in them and they're talking
about,
they really openly talking about all the shit that's in food now and what the
fuck they doing to animals because the food lobby was so strong.
They actually had a thing where they,
it was actually illegal to even say what was in the food.
Okay?
That's what kills me is what fucking sitting here going over to the Middle East,
fucking with these little pussy ass terrorist groups that have maybe 30,000
fucking members.
Isis,
let me tell you something,
right?
I would love to see isis attack Alabama and see how far is sure they could get
with their complete lack of planes and boats and all of this shit to fucking sit
there and act like these concert or any sort of a threat to us over here.
It's so fucking ridiculous and meanwhile you've got these people poisoning the
food supply.
That's not an act of terrorism.
It's fucking,
I don't know.
I'm on my soapbox now,
mom.
I fucking soapbox.
Okay.
It's dumb.
[inaudible] I could end the fucking terrorist groups over and fucking the Middle
East without firing a fucking shot.
All you do is just gradually get us on to electric and solar power over here.
Now granted,
this takes everybody following along and buying into it,
all right?
You know these Tesla cars and all that type of shit,
they don't need any fucking oil.
And then you just drill foil over here.
But whatever oil do you need,
you just gradually wean yourself off like Brazil did.
Okay.
Brazil did the same thing.
They don't have to give them any money.
And then what happens is they'll just go bankrupt all the money.
How do you think terrorists get fucking money?
They get,
they get money.
It's oil money that they fucking send it through the mosque through donations to
the religion and then they fucking break 'em off some.
It's a fucking joke.
So if we're not buying their oil,
they don't have any fucking money.
And then they go bankrupt and then you know what?
Then they got to go out and get a real fucking job and then that's it.
And then you know something,
we're also not over.
They're accidentally killing the wrong fucking people breeding more fucking
terrorists will be simple as shit.
Right.
Then maybe we come over here and focus on these carts that are feeding cows to
other cows.
Right.
When that makes sense.
Yeah.
You can have do it.
All he had to do is go to the Miami Dolphin game and look at the looks on the
fucking people's faces.
There's no way you could ever get that across to people because there's too much
money on the other side lying to people.
And they would just fucking buy into it.
And I know I completely oversimplified it,
but the biggest point in that all of that is Brazil did that.
Brazil does,
what do they go?
What do they run it on?
Cane sugar or whatever.
They just fucking used their own natural fucking resource over there and you
know what the hell they run their cars on.
Um,
but I read it at one point.
All right.
So anyways,
um,
Joe on there and there,
they're showing him a going out hunting and uh,
and these other people and it looked really,
uh,
I don't know.
It was really fucking amazing.
Um,
the see that type of angle.
I mean,
if you've got the fucking time and the money to go boar hunting,
I dunno.
It was interesting to me.
I just looked completely lost my train of thought as I'm sitting here looking at
this.
Oh,
I got to correct something that I said wrong on the Joe Perry podcast.
I thought the Paradise Club clothes like 20 years ago,
I actually fucked up what it was,
was they used to do these to do the WBCN um,
comedy riot there,
which was for the best up and coming comedian.
And um,
they stopped doing it there and then they started doing it.
It stitches,
stitches closed.
So I think that that's what I was thinking about.
I tried to say the Paradise Club closed and a,
it did not.
That's the same club that you two and the police is some really big bands and
what some of their first live gigs in the states.
They came over here.
Yeah.
Played.
And uh,
there we go.
Let's get into some more of the questions that this week.
Oh wait,
I got to read a couple more advertising things here.
We'll fucking blow through this year.
Um,
dollar shave club,
everybody,
big shape companies think,
must think we're a bunch of scumbag criminal swales.
Do they lock their razors up in that maximum security plastic razor fortress in
the shaving aisle?
Uh,
you have to stand around like a convict waiting for the guy to come and unlock
the razor case.
Do they think you're some kind of a jewel thief?
Next thing.
Oh.
Oh God.
Yeah.
God,
that's my fucking,
I didn't want to deal with that guy.
Yeah.
Below.
We found some more shit downstairs.
It's going to cost more fucking money.
Um,
you have to stand around like a convict waiting for the,
the guy to come unlock the razor case.
Do they think just some kind of a jewel thief?
Next thing there'll be a security guard who tasers you.
If you get too close to the razors,
you're not a criminal and you shouldn't get treated like one just because you
need a pack of razors.
Um,
if you're sick of getting humiliated every time you need razors,
there's only one thing you should do.
Join Dollar Shave club.com.
Their plants starts fucking phone.
Their plan starts at just $3.
Their blades are amazing.
They arrive like clockwork.
So you can shave with a fresh blade every week.
Nothing feels better than that.
Fresh Blade Shave a dollar shave club.com is the most convenient way to get a
great shave.
And they are the least expensive too.
Maybe if the big shave companies blades weren't so ridiculously expensive,
they wouldn't have to lock them up tighter than Fort Knox.
If anything is criminal,
it's the big shape.
Companies prices over a million.
People get their razors from dollar shave club.com um,
if you're not part of the club,
you're missing out.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr and check them out.
Now you won't.
Sorry.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr oh back to back two things that'll make your
life more convenient.
Razorblades top quality sent right to your door and never having to go to the
post office again.
stamps.com everybody with the holiday almost here.
You don't have time to go to the post office traffic parking.
It will be packed with everyone.
Mailing holiday gifts and packages.
So what?
So what,
so do what I do.
Sorry.
You stamps.com instead,
I swear to God I'm dyslexic with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassles of
going to the post office during the busy holiday season season.
Everything you would want to do with the post office,
you can do right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package the instant you needed.
Then the mailman picks it up so easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters whenever I want to sell crap at the
end of my shows.
And you know what?
You can use it.
You should do it too.
Right now.
Get this special offer when you go to my,
uh,
when you use my last name bur bur for a no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our,
that stamps.com enter burr.
Um,
all right.
Yeah,
this person brought this up here.
Paradise rock club,
deer,
wild bill.
Contrary to popular belief to Paradise Rock Club is still alive and well.
I'm only 21,
so I wasn't alive for the golden age of music,
but I've seen some good shit there.
Uh,
have you ever gone to see a band at a small venue than ended up being huge
anyways?
Love your show.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Did I ever see um,
no.
Jesus Christ fucking cigars?
No.
No it didn't.
Um,
no I didn't.
I have seen people that are now dead though.
You know,
um,
who died tragically,
I saw Stevie Ray Vaughan.
Um,
and then I've seen,
you know,
some of those heavy metals shows where guys live the life and died too young.
Uh,
but as far as that other stuff,
no,
I,
I haven't,
I would never went to the small venues.
I was really mainstream Billy back then.
I was listening to hair metal.
I mean,
what do you want from me?
All right.
Home purchase situation.
Billy,
my girlfriend and I just purchased our first home.
Congratulations.
I hope you don't run into the problems that I've run into.
He said,
I'm brand new from a builder.
During the upgrade selection session,
our sales woman was aloof,
dropping tiles,
dropping her computer,
slurring,
et cetera.
She didn't give any firm prices and wouldn't provide a written price list of
optional upgrades.
Oo,
that's all.
It's all a major red flag.
She's on some sort of drugs.
She's aloof and she's not giving you the information you need to make an
intelligent decision.
I hate this.
I hate how this is going.
So far.
After our visit,
we emailed her upgrades that we might be interested in,
but asked her to from prices so we could decide.
Three days pass,
no response.
So we emailed the build a directly to ask for a few,
uh,
for a new sales rep.
In the email.
We of course speculate that she may have been boozing.
Boy,
were we wrong.
He tells us that she is in fact the survivor of a traumatic brain injury.
Even worse,
about a day later,
I get an email to connect with her.
On linkedin and she shares the same last name is the builder.
Oh God.
So basically we called his wife a drunk after something clearly terrible happen.
Is this guy going to build us a piece of Shit House or do you trust that we will
be okay?
Would you wash your hands of this and buy something else?
Thanks for all that you do and go fuck yourself.
MMM.
I Dunno.
Is He deliberately going to build it like shit and risk getting sued?
Probably not,
but uh,
you know,
uh,
you definitely got to try to clear the air there,
but you know,
I mean,
what the fuck brain injury and not,
you've got to give us what we're asking for here.
Um,
AH,
Jesus.
That's God.
Blimey.
I can't even make any comedy out of that.
That's just fucking tragic.
Uh,
I mean,
yeah,
you could always just,
I mean,
if he hasn't started the job,
you could always move on.
MMM.
But you know,
they should say so they should fucking say something to you.
Somebody's gonna be slurring and drop and shit on the floor.
Just give me a heads up.
Okay.
You know what,
you,
you got a,
yeah,
you got hoodwinked there.
That right there would not hold up in a court of law.
What,
what dad?
That was entrapment.
You can't do that to people.
So yeah,
I wouldn't feel that.
I mean you feel bad a human to human level,
but don't feel bad like you,
you,
it's like you knew that.
Okay.
You know with all these fucking shows on TV,
but interventions.
How did you know that she wasn't drunk on the fucking job?
All right,
I got to get running here.
Let me just blow through these last two.
Transcending meditation.
Dare Bill Bergen stock.
Loved the show.
What?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Um,
I want,
wanted to hear your opinion pinion on something called transcendence,
trans transcendental meditation.
I can't even say it.
I don't know what that is.
Is that the one where you,
you're laying on the floor,
but you flew up.
Feel like you've floated out of the room.
Very quick story.
I'm 21 year old film store,
a student and I fell in love with David Lynch films ever since I found out about
them six months ago.
I've always wanted to make stories like this,
but never found that creative spark.
I looked up more about him and found out it was a big advocate.
Advocate of TM.
Thank you for abbreviating that.
Okay.
Transcendental,
transcendental meditation.
Actually,
in fact,
he created a whole organization dedicated to teaching poverty schools,
uh,
TM and also claims most of his creativity to it sounds pretty good so far.
I really believe that meditation can benefit people very much.
However,
here is where it starts to sound odd.
In order to learn TM,
you must have a certified TM instructor teach you how to do it over a week for
around 1500 bucks.
They say you need an instructor because he gives you a personal mantra,
which is the core of t m I'm very concerned.
Yeah.
I'm very conflicted about TM because on one hand,
many people I look up to and respect,
support TM such as Jerry Seinfeld,
Martin Scorsese,
Clint Eastwood,
and a ton more,
uh,
celebrity TM list.
However,
on the other hand,
something doesn't feel right about charging $1,500 for something that they claim
is very simple to understand.
If it was so helpful and simple,
why don't they just make a youtube tutorial about it?
Somebody probably did is a lot more that I left out because I didn't want to
bore anyone not interested.
A TM counter argument,
TM benefits.
Just wanted to hear your op,
uh,
your your option.
Have a blessed day and go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
I mean I would just go on youtube.
I would learn how to do it,
you know,
I used to actually be able to meditate,
and get that feeling where I felt like,
you know,
as I was laying on the floor and just picture my stomach going up and down,
focusing on the breath,
all of a sudden my stomach would feel like it was like 30 feet away from my head
all of a sudden.
And I felt like I was floating in my head and it was awesome.
And then somewhere along the line as I was meditating,
I would start to get to that place and I would be started to think like,
oh good,
it's happening here.
Here we go.
I'm going to start feeling like I'm floating.
And then it makes it go away.
And,
uh,
I haven't been able to get past that block cause you have to not give a shit
cause it got really fucking frustrating.
So,
um,
you know,
I would,
I dunno,
I would just keep talking about it to people and eventually you'll,
you'll fucking meet somebody and they could give you some tips,
you know?
Okay.
Mega teach you how to do some shit.
I don't think you need to pay $1,500 to learn how to meditate.
I would imagine that this is something that throughout I,
it's not something we learned how to do within the last 20 years.
This would probably have been done for centuries and parents probably just
taught it to their kids.
So I don't think that you need something like that.
Um,
I bet this,
there's gotta be another way to do it.
All right.
I gotta wrap this thing up.
Uh,
all right.
Real quick.
Got kicked out of Mcdonald's.
Drive Thru.
Dear Billy red ticks this past,
this past week,
four of my friends came over to my house to drink some beers.
Uh,
well we got drunk and like most drunk people,
we started that we were hungry.
So we asked our sober friend Bull Shit,
you did a don't drink and drive.
Fuck you.
Y'all jumped in the car,
hammered.
Uh,
if he can take us to Mcdonald's,
we hopped in his car and get to the drive through a,
welcomes us and asked for our order.
My F my other friend being drunk in the back seat said,
dude,
you should get a number.
I sober friend who was driving,
asked the girl working the drive through if he could get her number.
Now keep in mind that we don't even know what this lady looks like.
Immediately the lady flips out and says,
if you're going to do that then you should just leave after that.
She said that all of us in the car start after she said that all of us in the
car start pleading,
telling her we just want some mic chickens.
Uh,
she is still not having it and it says that we need to leave.
We leave and ended up going to Jack in the box.
So my question for you is,
did we deserve to get kicked out or was it a cunt move from this girl.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Well,
I wasn't there so I didn't hear how you asked.
But the way that you guys tell the story,
no you shouldn't have.
But um,
you know,
we live in a world right now where anything,
anything that a man does in the direction of a woman is some sort of a sexist
thing.
Rape.
Um,
no more.
It's just,
I mean,
I dunno why.
I Dunno.
Like the last year and a half,
all of a sudden it's just like you just sitting at home and a,
as a guy at this point,
at least I do.
It's like,
do we do anything right ladies?
Is there anything that we do that doesn't make you feel like a second class
citizen that could be violated physically or sexually?
You know,
there's a bunch of sweetheart guys out there.
You wouldn't know it.
You wouldn't know it by watching these fucking Goddamn fucking they,
they drive me nuts after a while after like the 2000 commercial them talking
about how difficult it is for them to do something because they have a vagina.
You just want to be like duty.
Do you think my life's a cakewalk?
Is that what you think it is?
That's like sort of the whole basis behind so much of that complaining.
You know,
my life is harder than yours and despite the fact I've never been you and
attempted to achieve something,
I somehow know exactly how easy your life is.
Even though if you ever tried to,
to,
to suggest that you realized anything about my life,
I would flip out on you for speaking for me as a woman.
But I will speak for you as a man all fucking day long.
It's all a bunch of fucking horse shit.
All right.
You know they should make the same amount an hour.
And you know the amount of people actually out there hitting women,
I mean the fucking commercials on that.
You would think that it was fucking,
you'd walk down the street and it's just women land littering the fucking
sidewalk from getting dropped.
You know what I mean?
And then what's funny is the fucking guys who actually,
you know,
tried to cover it up or now yelling at people like me who don't do it with their
commercial,
trying to get the dirt off of them.
I,
I've had it,
I've fucking had it with all of them even.
And I hate,
I'll fucking,
sports is just becoming like this for your cause.
Okay.
They're not even sports fans.
He's fucking people who aren't sports fans going in with their fucking,
because you know,
those stand up for cancer things that they were doing during the world series.
I have friends who die of cancer,
but I would never fucking do that to somebody in the middle of a baseball game.
Or are you going to a movie and just tap somebody on the shoulder?
Hey,
hit pause in the movie eight.
By the way,
just let you know there's people suffering from cancer and a good friend of mine
died of cancer and by the end of it I could picked him off the bed sheet with
two fingers.
All right.
Go back to the movie and enjoy yourself.
I think it's unbelievably intrusive and it's fucking rude,
you know what I mean?
I don't know.
That's just my fucking thought.
All right,
everybody knows this.
Cancer.
Everybody knows it's awful and everybody's fucking giving money to it.
All right?
Again,
not getting enough fucking money.
And this is what kills me.
So many of those fucking groups will you give him the money,
the amount of money that actually goes to the people with,
with uh,
cancer,
the amount of money that actually goes to the women that are being beaten.
The actual money that actually trickles down after you get through that fucking
Mesh corporate fucking structure is a joke.
And I'm telling you,
the NFL with that pink lady,
they were about ready to get busted.
If you notice there was way less pink this year.
And you know that wasn't because fans were bitching cause they don't give a fuck
cause they're all about the fucking bottom line.
I'm telling you this shit was about ready to hit the fan and they're going to
slowly walk away from each other and I guarantee you in 10 years,
seven,
10 years,
the real story will come out.
The NFL will pay a little bit of a fine,
but most people who perpetrated the fine will not be there anymore.
And they'll just be like,
well you know,
we're looking into that.
That was definitely something we wished didn't happen.
Um,
all right,
that's my negative shift for this fucking week.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
And uh,
oh dude,
I didn't even bring up the Bruins dude.
I just didn't have the time.
This week to fucking brutal loss is five to one against a maple leafs.
Five to one against the Canadians.
Canadians rolling along looking good.
We got back on track beat and the hurricanes.
Yeah,
that was definitely a bad fucking week.
So whatever,
it's still only November.
What are you going to do?
But,
um,
I dunno.
Canadians are looking good man.
I hate to Canadians so much.
I actually follow them on my phone.
I actually have their app just so I can keep up to see if they're winning or
losing and just sit there rooting against them.
It's fucking hilarious.
I'm rooting against him and they're leaving me texts.
Like,
second period,
we're up to one go habs go.
And I'm like,
fuck dude.
To my phone.
That's not that bad.
But you know what I mean.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.